ps5's new 3d audio isn't gonna work on
your tv at launch
bethesda just announced a few surprise
collections that you can play today
and blizzard versailles will be
reportedly closing its doors
i'm persia and this is your save state
for tuesday october 6th
[Music]
ps5's newest 3d audio feature will be
available at launch for your headset
but not for your tv we're going to have
to wait until a later date for that the
news comes via a playstation blog post
where sony showed off the upcoming
pulse 3d wireless headset that sony says
will be the best way to experience the
ps5
3d audio capabilities you'll also be
able to use any usb headset plugged into
the console
or 3.5 millimeter jack plugged into the
dual sense controller
as far as the tvs speakers getting
access to the 3d audio
sony's post also said it's still a
feature we are extremely excited about
and our engineers are hard at work at
bringing it to the ps5
in the future keep in mind that not all
games will support 3d audio though a few
games already confirmed to support this
feature
are spider-man miles morales demon souls
and resident evil village we're going to
be talking about this and a whole lot
more on this week's episode of
generation next so
check that out this friday if you want
more details
surprise bethesda announced a few
collections for some of its biggest
games today and they're available to
play
right now on xbox one and ps4 for the
wolfenstein fans out there the first
collection
includes four wolfenstein games in all
the new order
the old blood the new colossus and
youngblood and it's gonna cost you about
80 us bucks the second is the arcane
collection and it includes prey
dishonored and dishonored 2
along with the standalone dishonored 2
expansion death of the outsider
this comes weeks after microsoft bought
bethesda but we got clarification that
both collections will be playable on the
next-gen consoles through backwards
compatibility
so which one are you gonna pick up
bloomberg reported this morning that
blizzard will be closing its offices
in versailles france blizzard originally
planned to relocate half of the office
to london but the combination of brexit
and coronavirus changed that
it's unclear as of now how many
employees will lose their jobs or be
relocated but our hearts go out to
everyone on the team the versailles
office was responsible for marketing
providing customer support and
localizing blizzard games across
europe and this will mark the end of the
company's history in france
staff will apparently hear more next
week and we'll be keeping an eye on this
story as it develops and
hoping for the best that's a wrap on our
news for today but if you want to stay
up to date on some other things
in games be sure to check out our very
own dave jewett's
video we just posted about baldur's gate
3 on our channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
tomorrow on your next save state
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you